my father hadn't even stepped outside
the country his entire life let alone
sort of recently
and yet peter attwood became britain's
first covid 19 victim exactly
a year ago i felt a little bit silly but
gut instincts told me this was what dada
died of
84 years old he went into hospital early
january 2020.
he passed away on the 30th doctors
believed from bronchial pneumonia
it was only because as the months went
on we went into lockdown and we were
seeing
how these people were dying and how ill
they were and their respiratory problems
and their lungs were filling up and they
couldn't breathe
that was my dad so when i saw my dad in
hospital and i saw the pictures
on the news of people i've related that
to my dad
jane asked for a test months later it
was confirmed
her father was the first known covid19
related death in the uk
a month earlier than previously thought
raising questions
about when the virus arrived in britain
the official timeline runs like this
on the 31st of december the world health
organizations officially told
about a new pneumonia-like illness in
china on the 7th of january
peter atwood from kent is admitted to
hospital on the 11th
the first known death from kovid 19 in
the chinese city of wuhan
then the 30th peter atwood dies the same
day
the world health organization declares a
global emergency
on the 31st of january two chinese
nationals in york
are confirmed to have the virus believed
at the time
to be the first uk cases there were many
similar stories of people particularly
going
to europe on skiing holidays coming back
with the infection that met all the
classical criteria we know now so
i'm pretty sure it was uh definitely
here
with us in december there are some cases
going back to november but
they're less of them and it's
it's less clear and definite that they
had the disease
unconfirmed media reports suggest the
first cases of suspected covid in china
may have been november 2019 and peter's
daughter
wants answers as the anniversary of her
father's death
coincides with the week the uk death
toll
topped 100 000. sooner or later you know
another virus will come knocking on our
door
and we need to learn from these mistakes
i'd hate for this to happen again and
people to go through
what me and loads of other families have
gone through adele robinson sky news